europa entre la espada y la pared se
acercan las fiestas navideñas y la
rápida expansión de la variante omicron
por el continente preocupa a la
comunidad internacional se está moviendo
muy rápido
hemos visto con omicron que hay muchas
cosas que todavía no sabemos sobre o
micro esa es la verdadera asunto la
realidad es que hay mucha incertidumbre
hay lagunas de datos como consecuencia
se amplían las cuarentenas países bajos
donde apenas el 9% de la población
adulta cuenta con una dosis de refuerzo
inicio un cierre estricto este domingo
31 formales son 20 eso es inevitable
debido a la quinta ola que viene hacia
nosotros con la variante omicron que se
está extendiendo incluso más rápido de
lo que nosotros hemos tenido y por eso
debemos actuar ahora para prevenir al
máximo los peores escenarios un rumor
que tuvo como el anuncio irónicamente
provocó aglomeraciones en los centros
comerciales de quienes quisieron
prepararse antes del confinamiento total
en españa alemania francia y bélgica
miles de personas salieron a las calles
para manifestarse en contra de los pases
sanitarios y ya estamos aquí porque no
estamos de acuerdo con el certificado
kobe
creemos que el certificado coi es
discriminatorio
singh hace una distinción entre las
personas que se han vacunado y las que
no se vacunan así que es un régimen de
apartheid y todo el mundo tienen que
vacunarse sí o no según la organización
mundial de la salud o micrón ya fue
detectada en 89 países y los casos
relacionados con esta variante se
duplican cada 1.5 y 3 días